the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i want to have a look at house of
the dragons new weeks ahead trailer that
way we all have an idea of what will be
happening in the following episodes we
will be looking at scenes from not only
the second episode of house of the
dragon but most likely episodes 3 4 and
even beyond so you might want to wait
for my next video if you don't want to
know what will be happening in the next
few episodes now let's begin
other than maybe the opening scene it
looks like we will finally be leaving
king's landing after spending nearly the
entire first episode in that one
location soon we will be back on
dragonstone where daemon will face off
against serrato hightower after viserys
learns his brother had stolen one of the
dragon's eggs once again daemon will
upset his brother viserys by stealing
this egg from osaria and what he thought
would be their future son like many
targaryens before daemon was hoping to
set this dragon egg next to the newborn
baby in hopes of creating an immediate
bond with the dragon inside the ceres
will send serato to not only get the egg
back but make sure daemon knows that
massaria is no longer welcome in the
city it looks like this will be one hell
of a heated standoff that even brings
out rhaenyra and her massive
fire-breathing machine gun cyrex we even
get a glimpse of someone scaling the
rocks of what looks like dragonstone
this might even be daemon when he's
going after the dragon egg but it's
still hard to say right now we also get
a glimpse of viserys and alison and this
shows us that their relationship is
growing each day this was set in motion
near the end of the first episode when
serato showed no signs of hesitation by
sending his daughter to look after
viserys shortly after he had just lost
his wife and newborn son
if you look at one of these other images
you will see just how far this
relationship will go in this scene
alison now has the king's son inside of
her this will be the first of many
children they have further driving a
wedge in between rhaenyra and allison's
own relationship with one another we
then see a shot of someone walking in
front of balerion the black dread skull
this looks like it could be rhaenyra
although i'm not exactly sure what she
is up to my guess is she's heading for
her own dragon then a destination
unknown we then see a new castle off in
the distance in this scene here it kinda
looks like a smaller version of
harrenhal but i'm not exactly sure where
this is either one thing it does is get
me excited to be seeing new locations i
hope they do find ways of adding some
more adventure to the show now that the
stage is mostly set in we've met most of
the main characters we should be leaving
king's landing for new locations in the
following episodes which like i said has
me excited next we see rhaenyra sailing
out at sea as she looks up at daemon's
dragon karaxis as it damn near flips
over the ship this might be when
rhaenyra is on her way to driftmark the
seat of house velaryon located right
beside dragonstone eventually rhaenyra
will marry lord corliss valerion's son
leonor velaryon we've seen them walking
side by side on the shore of his home on
driftmark as you can see rhaenyra is not
very interested and we will soon find
out that lenore isn't very interested in
her either their relationship will
mostly serve as an alliance rather than
an actual love interest we then begin to
see the characters later in the season
when they're much older here is the
older version of rhinera and my guess is
this is when she's on dragonstone i say
that because it looks like the older
version of her father shows up there as
well now if this isn't on dragonstone
then it will be drift mark because they
do look very similar since they're both
islands surrounded by water this is
definitely on dragonstone where she
seems to be looking out over the sea
where we've seen her stand before i'm
thinking she's reflecting on everything
that is happening around her after she
loses her father and the iron throne
this is set up again when we hear
rhaenys tell rhaenyra that men will set
the realm on fire before ever seeing a
woman on the iron throne as we all know
rhaenys has first-hand knowledge because
she was also passed over for another man
when rhaenyra's father won the iron
throne in the opening scene of the show
during the great council of 101ac now
with all that being said we still hear
rhaenyra say i will be the queen of the
seven kingdoms something that's also
very reminiscent of daenerys targaryen
we hear rhaenyra say this as we get a
glimpse of her black council in
dragonstone this is after her father
dies and alison and serado have secured
king's landing before rhaenyra even knew
that her father was gone we already saw
how serato handled the death of
vasaris's son
he wanted the matter of succession
handled the same night well it will be
no different when viserys eventually
dies
he will make sure the matter is settled
in king's landing before rhaenyra even
finds out on dragonstone as soon as she
does find out what happened with her
father and the iron throne she forms a
council of her own now although rhaenyra
might have lost the iron throne she is
wearing the crown on her head the reason
she has the crown is because a member of
the kingsguard steals it from king's
landing before fleeing to dragonstone to
stand at her side here is actually a
shot of him handing her the crown this
is when we will really start to see
rhaenyra and daemon's relationship
flourish not only do we see them
standing side by side but we've also
seen glimpses of them getting married as
you can imagine this is only one of the
many relationships we will see daemon
targaryen engage in i mean what can i
say the man likes to dip his feather in
some ink now one other thing that was
set up in the first episode was this
conflict on the stepstones eventually
daemon and lorcorlus will leave king's
landing and driftmark to embark on a
journey to carve out a kingdom of their
own here we will most likely see the
biggest battle from this season
now since the war for the stepstones
lasts for several years i'm thinking we
might see more than one battle on these
islands
eventually daemon will name himself the
king of the stepstones and lord corliss
will set a crown on his head daemon
shows up in king's landing wearing the
crown which must infuriate his brother
viserys that's why we see him with a
blade at daemon's throat this is
interesting because viserys did support
his brother's efforts in the stepstones
and when daemon arrived back in king's
landing he did offer up his crown to his
brother however as we've seen in the
first episode already daemon has been
getting under his skin for a while
viserys finally snaps after dealing with
all of his shenanigans and then last but
certainly not least we will start to see
more dragons in the following episodes
we still need to see rainey's dragon
melees and aemons future dragon veigar
and many many more the showrunner said
we will see nine dragons this season and
in one of these shots we can see at
least seven of them flying above king's
landing i think it will be glorious when
we finally see this many big ass dragons
flying in the sky at once it's one of
the many things i'm looking forward to
after looking at all these amazing
scenes it does look like this season
will only get better and better from
here on out i know i cannot wait to see
how the rest of this season will unfold
like i've said before make sure you
subscribe so you can see all of my new
videos as soon as they are released i
still have more videos coming this week
and i will be making several videos
during each week of the season so stay
tuned for a lot more videos heading your
way as always i want to thank all of you
for watching this video i hope you all
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you